Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt, das Leben, das Universum und den ganzen Rest in Zusammenarbeit mit dem Zeiss Großplanetarium in Berlin. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ja, heute steht die 64. Sendung an. Allerdings dreht es sich in gewisser Hinsicht mehr um eine andere Zahl, nämlich die 42. Und ja, im Mittelpunkt soll eine Expedition stehen, eine Expedition ins Weltall. Und ich freue mich sehr, hier das erste Mal einen Gast das zweite Mal zu begrüßen, nämlich Samantha, Samantha Cristoforetti. Hallo. Willkommen zurück. Wir hatten vor fünf Jahren schon mal das Vergnügen. Und damals, naja, da stand alles noch vor dir. Da war sozusagen der Beruf schon festgelegt. Du bist Astronautin, du hast ja, schon immer zu den Sternen geschaut, bist gut gefördert, motiviert worden in deiner Jugend, um dann 2009 tatsächlich Astronautin zu werden. Wir haben dann viel gesprochen über den komplizierten Auswahlprozess und natürlich auch das ganze Training, was man dann annimmt. Was damals noch nicht klar war, ist, wann es denn zu einer Mission kommen wird. Dann hatten wir noch mal die Gelegenheit, gemeinsam ein wenig Schwerelosigkeit zu testen. In dem Parabell-Flug, den wir ja damals gemeinsam gemacht haben, mein einziger, für dich definitiv nicht der einzige. Da hattest du dann auch freundlicherweise meinen Hekelschwein aus der Schwerelosigkeit befreit, wofür ich ewig dankbar sein werde. Ja, und danach im Juli 2012 war es dann so weit. Es wurde dann die Mission zugewiesen, die Mission 42. Was für ein Glück. Genau genommen ja 42 und 43, um dann letzten Endes ungefähr ein halbes Jahr im All zu sein. Damit ist dann, glaube ich, auch diese ganze damalige neue Astronauten-Crew mittlerweile zumindest terminiert. Also ich glaube noch Thomas Pesquet ist der Einzige, der jetzt noch seine Reise antreten muss. Aber auch da gibt es jetzt schon eine Mission. Sprich, das neue Team ist jetzt dann schon gar nicht mehr so neu. Ja, und da möchte ich mal einsteigen. Wie war das, als so die Mission zugeteilt wurde? Was denkt man da? Weil da wird es ja auf einmal ernst.
Ja, es war bei mir sozusagen ein bisschen progressiv, weil schon ein Jahr davor, also in 2011, also 2010, wurden wir hier fertig mit unserem Business Training und 2011 wurde ich eigentlich Reserve Astronaut für ESA. Das war so ein Begriff, wo man gesagt hat, für die kleine Agenturen, zum Beispiel eben ESA, oder die Japaner oder die Kanadier, die haben nicht so viele Astronauten, da soll eine Astronautin oder ein Astronaut irgendwie immer einsatzbereit, also auf einem bestimmten Niveau trainiert werden, wenn der mal oder die mal reinspringen muss, damit man da den Platz nicht verliert, als kleine Agentur, als kleinere Agentur. Und deswegen durfte ich eigentlich schon in 2011 anfangen, so zu trainieren, als ob ich eine Mission schon hätte. Und das war natürlich sehr spannend. Also ich war kurz, also ein paar Monate nach unserem Gespräch, da im Sommer 2011, dann war ich in Strasit im Sternenstädtchen und da durfte ich monatelang intensiv mich mit Assozius beschäftigen und da wurde dann praktisch qualifiziert als Sportingenieur in den darauffolgenden Monaten. Und dann hat man angefangen über diese Mission 2014 zu reden. Und ja, es war natürlich im Gespräch, dass ich die vielleicht bekomme. Und ja, es ist immer alles ein bisschen progressiv. Es ist nie eine ganze Überraschung. Aber man weiß, bis das wirklich irgendwo schrecklich steht, kann sich noch alles ändern. Und dann, Mitte 2012 war es dann so weit, dass es auch wirklich schwarz auf weiß stand. Und dann ist man natürlich auch ein bisschen erleichtert, dass alles geklappt hat. Ja, und wie du sagst, dann wurde es natürlich ernst. Also dann wusste ich, dass dann in den nächsten 2,5 Jahren mein Leben dann wirklich nicht mehr mir gehörte, sondern den ganzen Planern, die dafür sorgen, dass es irgendwie klappt, dass man wirklich alle Trainingseinheiten überall in der Welt abhackt in den 2,5 Jahren.
Ja, Mission 42, den Witz haben dann auch alle mitbekommen. Da wurden auf einmal mehrere Identitäten sichtbar. Es gab dieses wunderbare NASA-Missionsfoto, nicht das erste, was so lustig war, aber definitiv sehr angemessen, wo ja alle so wie Mitglieder aus dem Buch per Einhalter durch die Galaxie Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy positioniert sind. Du hast irgendwie so eine spacige Waffe in der Hand, so eine Art Fernrohrwaffe. Da habe ich jetzt gar keine richtige Vorlage aus dem Buch im Kopf, oder war das einfach nur so?
Die gibt es im Film. Die gibt es im Film, ach so. Der Film ist ein bisschen geändert im Vergleich zum Buch, aber auch mit der Einwirkung von Douglas Adams. Ne, das war ganz lustig, weil ich ja, also als ich gewusst hatte, erfahren hatte, dass es 42 war, dann war es für mich klar, wir mussten unseren Poster mit der Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy machen. Alle meine Crewmitglieder, also Kollegen, die kannten, aber Douglas Adams gar nicht. Also der erste Schritt war natürlich, sie einzuführen in diese Welt, und dann haben sie das eigentlich mit Begeisterung aufgenommen. Und dann das Allerlustigste war, es gab dieser Trainer in Houston, er war damals der Trainer für die Space Toilette, für die Weltraumtoilette. Ein ganz lustiger Kerl und ganz begeistert für Douglas Adams. Und er kam eigentlich zu mir spontan und sagte, ich hab gehört, du willst diesen Poster machen, ich kann damit helfen, ich kann zum Beispiel diesen Gun machen. Also es ist jetzt kein Photoshop, der existiert wirklich, der hat das fabriziert. Und dann seine Frau, auch so ein begeisterter Science-Fiction-Fan, die war eigentlich eine Profikostümistin, also die hat ganze Kostüme gemacht. Und die kam zum Shooting, hat alles irgendwie nachgeguckt, dass alles irgendwie klappt, das ist unglaublich. Es ist kein Photoshop in dem, also ein bisschen Photoshop ist natürlich drin, aber die Kostüme und der Gun und so weiter, die existieren wirklich. Und das allerlustigste war, ich komme dann an diesem Vormittag von diesem Shooting und unser Commander, Butch Wilmors, war ein Navy-Pilot, ein ganz netter Kerl, aber auch ein ernsthafter Kerl. Und wie gesagt, bis vor ein paar Monate kannte er gar nicht. Und ich sehe, wie er da vor einem Spiegel steht und diesen Ausdruck mit dem Tee, mit der Tee-Tasse übt vor dem Shooting.
Das fand ich ganz, ganz lustig.
Ja, Tee produzieren im Weltraum, da kommen wir noch gleich dazu. Da gab es ja auch noch einen schönen Aspekt bei deiner Vision. Ja, und überhaupt, also damit war ja sozusagen, ich habe schon ein paar Rollen zusammengetragen, die ich so ausgemacht habe. In diesem Moment warst du ja im Prinzip Trisha McMillen, oder genannt Trillian sozusagen, die exponierteste weibliche Person im Anhalteruniversum. Ja, was gab es denn jetzt sozusagen unmittelbar im Vorfeld zur Mission? Was kam denn sozusagen dem Training jetzt noch hinzu? Also ich meine, man hat sich ja allgemein auf alles vorbereitet, aber jetzt wurde es ja konkret. Jetzt musste man sich ja im Prinzip auch schon mal einstellen, auf die wissenschaftlichen Experimente, die man letzten Endes begleitet. Wann setzt du das ein? Sofort nach der Bekanntgabe?
Nee, also mit den Experimenten selbst beschäftigt man sich eigentlich eh in den letzten sechs Monaten oder so, weil erst dann wird auch klar, was auf einen zukommt, experimentenmäßig. Davor ist ein bisschen, ja, es ist eigentlich lustig bei dieser Rotation von Crews, weil man ist zuerst Backup-Crew, also man muss eigentlich zum Start bereit sein, sechs Monate vor dem eigentlichen Start, weil da fliegt man eigentlich mit nach Baikonur und man ist bis zur letzte Sekunde irgendwie Backup-Crew. Man könnte im Prinzip einsteigen, wenn jetzt der Hauptcrew irgendwas passiert. Dementsprechend muss man eigentlich in den letzten sechs Monate vor dieser Backup-Runde beschäftigt man sich eigentlich mit den Experimenten, die die Hauptcrew dann machen soll, damit man auch für diese Experimente da einspringen kann, wenn das der Fall sein sollte. Und dann in den wirklich letzten sechs Monaten kommen auch, also es gibt natürlich meistens einen Unterschied und es kommen neue Experimente dazu, die dann wirklich auch für unsere Besatzung also dementsprechend geplant wurden. Und in den Jahren davor ist es mehr, man muss wirklich alle Systeme der Raumstation gründlich kennen. Das heißt gründlich natürlich, die Spezialisten auf dem Boden, das sind alle für ein System zuständig und das kennen sie tausendmal besser als wir. Wir müssen sie aber alle soweit kennen, dass wir sie bedienen können und dass wir sie zumindest in einen Safe Mode bringen können. Wenn da irgendwas passiert und wir haben keinen Kontakt zum Boden, dann müssen wir zumindest mal die Raumstation in eine sichere Lage bringen können, dass nichts weiteres kaputt geht. Das ganze Recovery, also von wirklich einer Panne oder so, dann würden dann wahrscheinlich die Spezialisten auf den Ground, auf dem Boden übernehmen müssen, weil die haben natürlich viel bessere Kenntnisse. Man trainiert sehr viel für Notfälle, also Feuer an Bord, ein Leck in der Raumstation, Ammonia, die irgendwie hereinkommt in die Kabine, das sind die die Hauptkrisenszenarien, auf die man sich vorbereitet. Für Weltraumspaziergänge trainiert man sehr viel, das ist ja auch ein sehr intensives Training. Um den robotischen Arm zu bedienen, trainiert man viel und dann das ganze Training in Russland natürlich, also gerade als Sportingenieurin, das war mein Fall. Man ist ja praktisch wirklich so ein ein Backup vom Kommandant, das heißt, man kennt sich so gut aus wie der Kommandant auf der Kapsel und man kann das auch manuell fliegen wie der Kommandant. Das heißt, es ist ein gutes Jahr insgesamt, das wird nicht kontinuierlich, sondern immer wieder drei Wochen, vier Wochen, sechs Wochen, immer wieder. Aber insgesamt kommt es schon zu mehr als einem Jahr Training nur für die Soyuz. Das ist ja wirklich nur sechs Stunden am Anfang und vier, fünf Stunden am Ende, aber das sind natürlich die kritischen Momente, also Start und Andocken und wieder Eintritt in die Atmosphäre und Landung.
Ja, sollten wir auf jeden Fall auch nochmal drüber reden, aber ich stelle gerade fest, sozusagen diese Position als Backup-Team, da sitzt man ja dann im Prinzip schon in Baikonur genauso mit diesem Bewusstsein, eigentlich könnte es jetzt auch losgehen. Ich weiß irgendwie alles, es könnte jetzt sogar passieren, es ist unwahrscheinlich, aber es könnte passieren. Also wenn es dann nicht passiert, ist man beim seinem ersten Mal eigentlich schon gefühlt so ein bisschen das zweite Mal da.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist eigentlich sehr angenehm, weil das ist jetzt nicht mehr so die große Entdeckung, weil am Anfang, das erste Mal, dass man nach Baikonur fliegt, dann hat man natürlich sehr viele Fragen, wie das jetzt alles abläuft und hat man alles vorbereitet und so weiter und so fort und wenn man das jetzt als Backup-Crew schon mal erlebt hat, das nimmt eigentlich schon den Stress weg, dann weiß man ganz genau, was man erwarten muss.
Als es dann aber wirklich dann mit der richtigen Mission losging, muss man erstmal einen Baum pflanzen, habe ich gelernt.
Stimmt, ja, das ist ja eine Tradition bei der Russen, das geht wirklich zurück bis zur Jury Gagarin. Es gibt so eine Allee, wo die Astronauten untergebracht sind für diese zwei Wochen Quarantäne. Da gibt es so eine Allee, wo wirklich alle Bäume sind, von allen Astronauten bis zur Gagarin. Also sein Baum ist natürlich jetzt sehr groß. Ja, und da gibt es ja diese nette Tradition, dass jedes Mal, dass ein Astronaut oder ein Kosmonaut zum ersten Mal aus Baikonur fliegt, wird ein Baum gepflanzt.
Nur beim ersten Mal?
Das heißt, jeder kriegt nur einen.
Das heißt, außer dir war das dann noch eine weitere Person, wenn ich das richtig sehe, oder?
Also da war schon mal der Weltraum auf dem Shuttle, aber zum ersten Mal aus Baikonur.
Das ist ja ein relativ verlassener Ort, dieses Baikonur, oder? Also da ist ja nicht viel, oder? Das ist im Wesentlichen so die große Lehre und mittendrin ist dieser Raumfahrtbahnhof, oder? Ist das doch ein bisschen aufregender?
Baikonur an sich ist natürlich eine Stadt. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, wie groß. Ich glaube, früher war die Bevölkerung vielleicht auch größer, als das auch wirklich zu Russland gehört hat. Inzwischen glaube ich ein bisschen eher verlassener. Ich habe die Stadt jetzt nicht so richtig erlebt, weil beides Mal war ich in Quarantäne. Das heißt, ich durfte durch die Stadt nur als Backup-Crew für diese offiziellen Besuche im Museum und bei den verschiedenen Denkmäler als Prime-Crew gar nichts. Man kommt aus der Quarantäne gar nicht raus. Deswegen kann ich zur Stadt nicht so weinslich viel sagen. Aber dann ja klar, außerhalb der Stadt gibt es der Kosmodrom. Das ist natürlich dann im Mitte von nichts.
Ja, das war dann auch so auf dem Weg zur Sojus TMA 13M.
15M.
15M? Ich will dann schlau sein. Da trägt man ja so diesen speziellen russischen Raumanzug. Er ist ja Sukhol. Und da hatte ich dann die nächste Assoziation, weil da sahst du so ein bisschen aus wie Prinzessin Leia. Durch diese eingebauten Kopfhörer in diesem Helm hat man sozusagen gleich die passende Frisuren-Assoziation. Aber das nur nebenbei. Das ist ja super eng in diesem Sojus-Ding. Da ist man ja so wirklich zusammengedrückt. Weiß nicht, warum das eigentlich so sein muss. Es ist einfach so wenig Platz wegen der ganzen Technik. Vermutlich. Oder gibt es irgendwie einen Grund, dass es von Vorteil ist, dass man so eng zusammengedrückt ist?
Nee, von Vorteil ist es auf keinen Fall. Mehr Platz wäre nett, aber die Sojus ist normal so groß. Die Rakete ist normal so groß. Die Sojus muss in die Rakete passen. Die Rakete ist so groß. Man muss ja irgendwie alles runterbringen können. So viel Platz für die Menschen bleibt nicht übrig. Da bist du natürlich froh, wenn du klein bist wie ich.
Also man steigt dazu dritt ein. Drei Leute passen ja nur rein. War das eigentlich schon dieser neue, schnelle Anflug zur Raumstation? Aber nicht das erste Mal, oder?
Nicht das erste Mal, das war schon seit einem Jahr so.
Genau, aber noch nicht vor so langer Zeit dauerte der Anflug? Zwei Tage. Was ist jetzt bei diesem neuen Anflug anders?
Es dauert eben eine kürzere Zeit. Die Russen haben irgendwann einfach festgestellt, dass sie inzwischen die Soyuz-Rakete auch sehr gut kennen. Sie können viel besser vorhersagen, in welchen Erdumlauf man ja auch kommt. Es gibt immer eine Streuung bei Raketen, das ist jetzt nicht immer 100% präzise. Und wenn man da das Zuverlässigen um die Vorhersagen kann, dann kann man die Soyuz so starten, dass sie auch wirklich direkt hinter der Raumstation ist. Und innerhalb von vier Umrundungen, also sechs Stunden, dann die Raumstation einholen kann. Also früher war es einfach so, dass man sich so nicht richtig zugetraut hat. Und man ist erstmal in die Erdumlaufbahn gekommen. Dann hat man ein paar Mal die Triebwerke gestartet, einfach um diesen Obid-Urlaubahn abzurunden und zu korrigieren. Und dann hat man nochmal geguckt, und dann hat man nochmal gerechnet. Und erst am nächsten Tag hat man es so gemacht, dass es wirklich die Soyuz auf dem Weg zum Raumstation gebracht hat. Und inzwischen kann man das einfach alles schneller machen, schneller rechnen, besser vorhersagen. Also die Möglichkeit, auf diesen zweitägigen Programm umzusteigen, besteht immer noch. Dafür werden auch die Crews trainiert. Also wenn es irgendein Problem gibt, wenn die Rakete doch nicht so funktioniert, wie man das erwartet hat, und die Soyuz in eine andere Orbit ein bisschen kommt, man kann immer sagen, okay, wir machen das jetzt auf zwei Tage. Und dann hat man alle Zeit, irgendwie zu überlegen, zu rechnen. Und das alles klappt und es ist auch passiert. Ich glaube zumindest einmal weiß ich ganz genau, dass sie jetzt so gestartet sind, dass sie in 6 Stunden ankommen wollten. Aber dann gab es ein technisches Problem und die sind dann erst nach 2 Tagen angekommen.
Das heißt, man ist dann wirklich 2 Tage so mit angezogenen Beinen?
Nein, in dem Fall. Es ist eigentlich im Prinzip sogar angenehmer, weil bei diesen schnellen Programmen, also ich zum Beispiel als Board-Ingenieur, ist es oft so, dass man aus dem Raumanzug gar nicht kommt. Zum Beispiel einen Toiletten-Break hat man gar nicht. Der Kommandier und der Ride-Seater kriegen das, das war auch bei uns der Fall, aber als Board-Ingenieur ist das ein bisschen schwieriger. Wenn man das über 2 Tage macht, kommt man eigentlich schneller aus dem Anzug und man kann sich einfach umziehen in mehr oder weniger normalen Klamotten, auf Toilette gehen und so weiter, weil das ist alles irgendwie verteilt auf 2 Tage. Es ist alles nicht so stressig.
Ich dachte, das wäre jetzt toller, aber naja gut.
Allgemein, ich glaube, es ist schon schöner, schneller anzukommen, aber es ist alles ein bisschen kompakter und zusammengedruckt.
Okay, 6 Stunden. Aber jetzt vielleicht nochmal kurz, ich weiß, das ist so eine Standardfrage, aber dieser Start einer Rakete, wie viel G hat man da sozusagen im Rücken?
Das baut sich langsam auf, weil je länger die Rakete oder die Stufe funktioniert hat, desto leichter wird die Rakete, weil Treibstoff wird ständig verbraucht und je leichter wird die Rakete, der Schub bleibt ungefähr der gleiche, das heißt, die Beschleunigung wird immer mehr und immer mehr. Am Anfang hatte man bei der Soyuz kaum das Gefühl, dass man sich bewegt, das ist jetzt wirklich sanft. Und langsam baut sich auf bis ungefähr auf 4 Gs, ein bisschen über 4 Gs, glaube ich. Und dann startet die nächste Stufe und es ist genau das gleiche wieder. Es baut sich langsam auf bis auf ungefähr 4 Gs. Nicht schlecht, ich fand es jetzt nicht schlecht. Ich fand es schlimmer bei der Rückkehr, weil man es dann nicht gewohnt ist. Man war jetzt in unserem Fall 200 Tage in der Schwerellosigkeit. Deswegen einfach nur ein G, einfach ein normales Gewicht, fühlt sich unangenehm an. Aber beim Start, wo man es eigentlich gewöhnt ist, fand es jetzt nicht so schlimm.
Aber es war auch, sagen wir mal, so wie trainiert. Also das Training hat die richtige Antizipation hervorgebracht. War das schon so, ja, kenn ich aus dem Training kein Problem?
Ja, also ich meine, diese 4-G-Beschleunigungen, die erlebt man eigentlich sehr oft in der Zentrifuge. Gerade jetzt als Kommandant und Bordingenieur, weil man den Wiedereintritt auch übt und die Prüfungen machen muss. Die finden eigentlich in der Zentrifuge statt. Und 4-G sind eigentlich normal auch ein bisschen mehr.
Das kennt man.
Wann merkt man in das erste Mal Schwerelosigkeit?
Also, wenn man in die Umlaufbahn gekommen ist, das heißt, die letzte Stufe vom Triebwerk schaltet sich aus, dann ist man schwerelos. Man ist aber auch sehr eng gebunden im Sitz. Das heißt, man fängt nicht einfach an zu schweben. Es ist mehr so, dass man merkt, dass alles schwebt. Also zum Beispiel die Checklist in der Hand, die schweben jetzt. Und dann hat man ein komisches Gefühl im Gehirn. Also ich hatte zum Beispiel am Anfang, ich glaube für ein halbes Stündchen oder so, dann hatte ich wirklich das Gefühl, dass ich jetzt nach vorne fallen würde. Also mein Gehirn hat gedacht, ich bin auf einem freien Fall nach vorne. War natürlich nicht der Fall. Aber mein Gehirn musste sich daran gewöhnen, dass es plötzlich keine Schwerkraft mehr gibt. Und dann, wenn man überprüft, dass es keinen Leck gibt in der Kapsel, dass wir auch unsere Luft behalten. Und wenn alles gut geht, dann gibt es so Milestones. Also ich glaube nach vielleicht 40 Minuten oder so. Wenn alles gut ist, dann kriegt man die Erlaubnis, diese Sicherheitsgurte zu lockern. Wenn man sagt, okay, es ist jetzt unwahrscheinlich, dass wir gleich einen Wiedereintritt einleiten müssen. Und man fängt ein bisschen an zu schweben im Sitz. Und dann natürlich toll wird es das erste Mal, dass man sich eigentlich abschnallen kann. Und man kann auch wirklich schweben und rumfliegen.
Dann geht ja eigentlich alles relativ schnell. Nach sechs Stunden ist man da. Das heißt, die Soyuz nähert sich der ISS quasi von hinten an. Wer sorgt dann dafür, dass die auch den richtigen Andockpunkt findet, macht man das aus der Kapsel heraus? Machen das die Astronauten an Bord der ISS?
Im Prinzip ist das vorprogrammiert im Computer. Das heißt, es ist alles selbst gesteuert. Wir überprüfen das nur. Und falls irgendwas passiert, wo der Computer versagt oder die Triebwerke versagen, irgendwas versagt, dann können wir das manuell übernehmen. Aber bei uns war es jetzt nicht notwendig. Wir haben einfach dazugeguckt und es hat alles super geklappt.
So, dann geht die Tür auf. Du warst die Erste, die ausgestiegen ist.
Es dauert noch ein bisschen, glaube ich ein paar Stündchen, bevor man die Türen sozusagen, die Schleusen aufmachen kann.
Ein paar Stunden?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Vielleicht haben wir uns ein bisschen beeilt, aber fast ein paar Stunden dauert es schon. Man muss ja überprüfen, dass da keine Lacks gibt bei den Interfaces, also diese Leak-Jacks.
Man kann nicht einfach mal eben die Tür aufmachen. Hurra, wir sind jetzt da.
Nein, wenn tatsächlich da was wäre, dann würde man natürlich Luft verlieren, auch von der Raumstation in dem Fall. Das wäre natürlich blöd.
Okay, also man muss nochmal durch ein vorsichtiges Checkprogramm durch.
Und dann ist man so weit, dass man dann die Schleusen aufmachen kann. Die Crews, die schon an Bord waren, das waren jetzt Sascha, Jelena und Butch. Die haben uns dann die Schleuse auf ihr Seite aufgemacht. Dann haben wir unsere Schleuse aufgemacht. Es ging alles ganz schnell. Wir hatten eigentlich gar nicht ausgemacht, wer als Erster da durchkommt. Dann sagte einfach der Anton, unser Kommandier, zu mir, schnell, schnell, geh durch.
Ist das richtig, dass es das erste Mal war, dass zwei Frauen an Bord der ISS gleichzeitig waren?
Es hat es früher gegeben.
Das gab es schon? Okay, habe ich jetzt nicht komplett nachgelesen.
In Erinnerung habe ich auf jeden Fall Tracy Dyson und Sharon Walker, die waren mal mit den Besatzungsmitgliedern zusammen. Vielleicht gab es auch andere, aber die weiß ich auf jeden Fall.
Okay, ja, dann war es jetzt so weit, oder? Also ich meine, so viele Jahre darauf hingeträumt, dahin trainiert, vorbereitet, gelernt, sich wahrscheinlich auch so mental so sehr darauf konzentriert. Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, wegen dieses Fluges, dass man da jetzt nicht groß romantisiert, sondern man ist halt einfach so sehr auch programmiert und auch so sehr Profi in dieser ganzen Geschichte, dass man eigentlich nur noch wie eine Maschine das alles abspult, weil dafür hat man ja nur mal trainiert. Trotzdem muss es ja irgendwann so einen Punkt, so einen Moment der Ruhe geben. Und wenn es nur das erste Mal im Schlafsack ist, wo man sich dann so denkt so, wow, it's happening.
Eigentlich schon auf dem Weg zur Raumstation, muss ich sagen, weil in diesen sechs Stunden da passiert eigentlich nicht so wahnsinnig viel. Also ich meine, die erste Stunde ist ziemlich stressig. Da muss man viel machen. Gerade als Sportingenieur des ganzen League-Checks und überprüfen, dass alle Systeme in Ordnung sind, damit man wirklich auch die Entscheidung trifft, okay, wir machen weiter, es gibt keine Probleme. Aber danach sind es noch zwei, zweieinhalb Stunden, wo man hin und wieder überprüft, dass die Triebwerke richtig arbeiten und so. Aber bis man hinkommt und in der Nähe der Raumstation ist, dann dauert es halt ein bisschen. Dann hat man eigentlich seine Ruhe. Man kann mal versuchen, mal raus zu gucken. Gut, das Fenster ist natürlich sehr klein, so gut sieht man nicht da raus. Aber ich meine, man kann schon die erste Blicke gewinnen von der Erde. Ich habe meinen ersten Sonnenaufgang gesehen, schon auf der Sojus. Naja, ein bisschen emotional ist es schon. Es ist jetzt nicht so maschinenmäßig, weil es eben nicht so... Es gibt ein paar Stunden, wo es nicht so viel zu tun gibt.
Wie warm ist es auf der ISS?
Nicht genug.
Da redet aber keiner drüber.
Man kann es im Prinzip so einstellen, wie man möchte. Aber für mich war es ein Stückchen kalt. Ich habe immer Sweaters getragen, also Pullis die meiste Zeit. Bei 22 Grad oder so, das ist völlig in Ordnung. Ich bin nur so eine, die leicht friert.
Was hat man da an? Es gibt ja so einen Bauernraum-Anzug.
Nein, nein, standardmäßig wirklich ein Baumwollen-T-Shirt und so Cargo-Pants. So diese Arbeitshosen mit ganz viel Velcro überall und Taschen, die dann praktisch sind zu arbeiten. Genau, das ist mehr oder weniger das Standard.
Und wonach riecht das Ganze?
Eigentlich ziemlich neutral. Also wir haben sehr, sehr gute Filter, so einen speziellen Geruch gab es nicht. Gut, wenn man jetzt wirklich mit der Nase hingeht, ein PMM, ganz am Ende, wo die ganzen Toiletten-Container gestapelt, nicht gestapelt, aber verstaut werden, bevor sie dann eingepackt werden mit Müll, für den Wetteneintritt in einen Müllcargo. Dann riecht es natürlich, klar, aber so allgemein in der Kabine oder so, dann ist es eigentlich sehr, sehr neutral. Was ganz speziell riecht, ist, wenn zum Beispiel ein Cargoschiff ankommt und dann baut man diese Verbindung zwischen dem Schiff und der Raumstation und wenn man jetzt die Schleuse auf unserer Seite aufmacht, dann ist praktisch die zugemachte Schleuse von diesem Raumschiff noch da und die war lange Zeit im offenen Weltraum. Und da kriegt ihr diesen Geruch von, ja, das ist, was wir jetzt Weltraumgeruch nennen, das ist natürlich, der Weltraum riecht nicht, aber das ist ja dieser Metall, der ausgesetzt wurde zum Vakuum vor eine feine Weile. Und das riecht eigentlich ziemlich unangenehm, ein bisschen wie ein Essen, das irgendwie schlecht geworden ist, mit einer Mischung von Verbrannten. Oder auch so Spacewalkers, also Leute, die auf einem Weltraum spaziergang waren, wenn sie dann wieder reinkommen, also die riechen auch ein bisschen so.
Und wie laut muss man sich das da vorstellen? Ich meine, da sind viele Maschinen, macht man sich immer nicht so klar.
Ja, vor allem Pumpen und Ventilatoren, da gibt es ganz viele, das ist schon laut. Also in einem Modul, von einer Seite von einem Modul bis zur anderen Seite, das sind vielleicht, was weiß ich, 6, 7 Meter oder so. Man muss schon laut reden, wenn man miteinander reden möchte. Und in einigen Modulen geht es gar nicht, weil die einfach zu laut sind. Zum Beispiel der Note 3, wo die ganze ICNES, also Life Support-Ausrüstungen drin sind, das sind so Ausrüstungen, die besonders laut sind, da gibt es besonders viele Pumpen und Ventilatoren usw. Da kann man eigentlich von einer Seite vom Modul bis zur anderen Seite gar nicht miteinander reden. Und über verschiedene Module, nur wenn man wirklich schreit. Sonst geht es gar nicht.
Aber ihr habt jetzt nicht Headsets an, manchmal? Ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt mit der Bodenstation unterhält, das ist ja auch ein wichtiges Thema, muss man ja Mikrofone benutzen.
Ja, meistens hat man so ein Mikro in der Hand, das jetzt eigentlich mit Kabel verbunden ist. Es ist eigentlich nicht so viel drahtlos auf der Raumstation im Moment. Und die Lautsprecher kommen einfach direkt durch die Lautsprecher. Es gibt meistens zwei in jedem Modul auf den beiden Seiten.
Weil so die Science-Fiction sagt ja immer, man kann sich ja immer miteinander unterhalten, egal wo man gerade ist. Alle haben irgendwelche Headsets auf, wie so Schiedsrichter auf dem Fußballplatz. Dem ist nicht so.
Ja, man müsste dann so ein drahtloses System haben. Also haben wir auf der Raumstation jetzt nicht. Wäre natürlich unter Umständen praktisch, aber ja.
Das heißt, man muss sich schon gegen diese permanente Lautstärke auch irgendwie durchsetzen? Oder gibt es auch einen Rauben, der jetzt bewusst leiser ist?
Es gibt Module, die leiser sind. Ja, z.B. der Columbus ist nicht so laut oder die japanischen Module, oder auch Nr. 2, also die Module da vorne sind relativ leiser. Wo wir jetzt schlafen in unseren kleinen Schlafkabinen, das ist alles ziemlich gut abgeschirmt. Die haben zwar auch einen Ventilator drin, weil die Luft muss ja zirkulieren. Man ist gut abgedichtet vom Geräusch außerhalb. Und es gibt ziemlich gute Abschirmungssysteme, weil der Raum ist eben dazu gemein, dass man drin schläft. Deswegen wurde auch so viel wie möglich gemacht, dass es leiser ist.
Ist es in der Kupola, in diesem schönen Aussichtsplattform, ist es da leiser?
Ja, die Kupola ist direkt an Nr. 3 dran. Wie gesagt, Nr. 3 ist ziemlich laut. Und gerade wenn jemand zum Beispiel auf T2 läuft, das ist der Laufband, dann wird es unheimlich laut.
Tja, da ist noch einiges zu verbessern. Aber es ist natürlich nicht einfach. Das Ganze ist ja im Prinzip einfach eine große Maschine. Das muss man sich immer wieder mal klarmachen. Was da alles produziert werden muss, Wasser muss die ganze Zeit aufbereitet werden, natürlich Stroh, etc. Alles macht man sich vielleicht auch gar nicht so richtig klar. Vielleicht mal kurz zu diesem Tagesablauf. Mein Tagesablauf ist ja schon mal ganz lustig, wenn während unserer 24 Stunden dort wie viele Sonnenaufgänge stattfinden? 16 pro Tag? 15, 16. Wie kriegt man da einen Tag hin? Also ich meine, es gibt schon eine 24-Stunden-Struktur, ganz klar, weil man muss ja auch mit der Bodenstation kommunizieren. Haben alle denselben Tages... also ist man synchronisiert? Also es gibt gemeinsames Frühstück sozusagen? Okay, könnte ja auch sein, dass es so eine 24-Stunden-Bereitschaft gibt, dass immer jemand wach sein muss? Das ist nicht so. Okay, also die ISS schläft auch irgendwann und dann passiert da einfach nix. Und dann geht's wieder los und wie lange ist so der Tageseinsatz?
Also ich meine, der Arbeitstag fängt typischerweise zwischen sieben und halb acht mit der Morning DPC, das ist die Daily Planning Conference. Das heißt, wir sind alle zusammen und wir reden der Reihe nach mit allen Kontrollzentren auf dem Boden. Also wir fangen mit Houston an und dann Hansville. Also Houston und Hansville sind natürlich beide in den USA, aber Houston ist mehr für die Systeme der Raumstation zuständig, also der Raumstation an sich, und Hansville ist mehr für die Experimente von NASA zuständig.
Also den amerikanischen Teil.
Den amerikanischen Teil. Und dann springen wir über den Atlantik und wir reden mit München über Pfaffenhofen. Das ist das Kontrollzentrum für das Columbus, also für die Systeme von Columbus, aber auch für die ganze ESA Wissenschaft an Bord. Das nennen wir Col-CC. Dann springen wir über zu Kuba in Japan. Und genauso sind sie zuständig für Kibo, das japanische Labor, Systeme und Wissenschaft. Und dann springen wir zurück nach Moskau und dann reden die russischen Kollegen meistens ziemlich lange mit Moskau. Und dann geht's los. Jeder hat einen Plan. Das wird jetzt nicht von uns ausgestellt, sondern von diesen Teams, von Planern auf dem Boden. Es gibt so eine alte Art elektronisches Kalender. Und dann gibt's so eine rote Linie, die runterkommt. Das ist die Timeline, wo man eigentlich sein sollte. Und man versucht da irgendwie damit zu halten. Also manchmal dauert irgendwas ein bisschen länger. Und dann muss man versuchen, da nachzuholen. Oder mit dem Boden abzusprechen, wie man das macht. Wie kann man das jetzt hinkriegen, dass das alles noch klappt. Manchmal geht alles reibungslos. Man ist auch schneller fertig als geplant, je nachdem. Das kann natürlich Experimente sein. Es kann Wartungsarbeit. Du hast es ja angesprochen. Die Raumstation ist eine riesen Maschine. Die braucht natürlich Wartung, Instandsetzung. Es kann sein, dass es jetzt ein spezieller Tag ist, wo ein Weltraumspaziergang stattfindet. Oder eben ein Raumschiff ankommt, so ein Cargoshiff. Das muss dann gefangen werden mit dem robotischen Arm. Es muss angedockt werden. Es muss auch wieder mal so Leak-Jacks gemacht werden. Es muss alles umgerüstet werden, damit man da die Schleusen aufmachen kann. Und dann gibt es auch sehr viel Cargoarbeit. Es muss alles ausgeladen werden. Das nimmt auch ein Stück Zeit. Beziehungsweise am Ende der Mission von diesem Schiff muss das Schiff auch wieder beladen werden. Entweder mit Müll, wenn das jetzt destruktiv wieder reinkommt. Oder eben mit Sachen, die dann zurück auf den Boden kommen, müssen zum Beispiel mit einem Dragon, das eigentlich heil wieder auf die Erde bzw. in den Ozeanen kommt. Manchmal gibt es auch Öffentlichkeitsarbeiten. Wir können mit Schülern oder Studenten reden, dort mit Media. Das sind auch so kleine Aktivitäten, die dann im Plan drin stehen.
Was waren denn jetzt deine Experimente, mit denen du dich im Wesentlichen beschäftigen musstest oder die betreut werden mussten?
Es ist ein bisschen schwer, jetzt alles zu erzählen, weil in sechs Monaten gibt es natürlich viele. Also insgesamt auf der Raumstation laufen zwischen 200 und 250 Experimente in sechs Monaten. Man beschäftigt sich nicht mit allen. Also erstens ist das ein bisschen aufgeteilt. Nicht jeder Astronaut arbeitet mit jedem Experiment. Und es gibt auch Experimente, die im Hintergrund laufen, mit denen wir eigentlich gar nichts zu tun haben, außer es gibt irgendwelche Probleme. Und dann braucht man irgendjemanden damit händen.
Also so die ganzen Dauerinstallationen.
Genau.
Das Alpha-Magnet-Spektrometer, da steht zum Beispiel da oben rum und keiner muss sich groß drum kümmern.
Ja, genau, da werden die Datendirektoren zum Boden geschickt.
Ja, ich meinte jetzt auch gerade so konkret Experimente, mit denen du sozusagen mehr zu tun hattest als vielleicht jetzt mit dem Rest.
Ja, das sind meistens die Experimente, wo man als Astronautin auch Subjekt vom Experiment ist. Dann sind dann die, die die meiste Zeit dann auch in Kauf nehmen. Zum Beispiel, ich hatte Experimente, wo man den Rückfluss vom Blut vom Gehirn zum Herz untersucht hat. Das war eigentlich das erste Mal, dass man das angeguckt hat. Das ist eigentlich auch relativ intuitiv auf der Erde. Wenn man steht, dann hilft die Schwerkraft. Man möchte eigentlich verstehen, was der Mechanismus ist im Weltraum. Das ist wahrscheinlich eh ähnlich zu dem, was jetzt auf der Erde ist, wenn man liegt. Das heißt, es ist nicht mehr so sehr die Schwerkraft, es ist mehr so die Atmung. Das wollte man untersuchen, und das war eigentlich auch interessant, weil dadurch hat man auch so Diagnostikverfahren entwickelt, die relativ einfach sind. Und diese Teams, die wollen die dann auch klinisch jetzt einsetzen auf der Erde. Wir haben Atmungsprozesse untersucht, auch zum ersten Mal. Also was passiert in den Lungen? Also da gibt es dieses Austausch von Gasen bei der Atmung. Und es wurde eigentlich nie untersucht, was jetzt in der Schwerelosigkeit passiert, ob sich das ändert und wie sich das ändert. Das war auch so ein neues Experiment, Airway Monitoring. Und es war eigentlich ganz lustig, weil wir einen Teil von diesem Experiment bei niedrigerem Druck machen mussten. Deswegen war wir eigentlich im Airlock eingesperrt und wir haben dann den Druck dann erniedrigt. Es gab kognitive Experimente. Also da musste ich eigentlich ziemlich lange, also stundenlang, jetzt eine Reihe von Aufgaben machen, wo die Wissenschaftler untersuchen wollten, wie sich das Gehirn anpasst an die Schwerelosigkeit im Sinne von Gleichgewicht und Kontrolle von der Bewegung und wie schnell diese Anpassung stattfindet. Dann gab es Experimente über den Schlaf. Dann habe ich mehrere Nächte so ein ganz enges T-Shirt tragen müssen, wo ganz viele Sensoren drauf waren, mit denen die Wissenschaftler die Schlafmuster untersuchen konnten. Dann gab es ein Experiment über zirkadianische Rhythms. Wie ändert sich das Tag-Nacht-Rhythmus? Nicht so sehr subjektiv, wie das der Astronaut empfindet, sondern wie sich der Körper physiologisch anpasst. Das ist korreliert mit der Temperatur. Man musste 36 Stunden lang komische Sensoren tragen, die die Körpertemperatur dann ständig gemessen haben. Dann gibt es natürlich Experimente, nicht direkt auf den Körper vom Astronaut, sondern auf Zellen. Es gab Experimente mit Stammzellen, wie differenzieren sie sich anders in der Schwerelosigkeit als auf dem Boden. Oder auf Knochenzellen. Bei einem Experiment hat man untersucht, ob spezielle Arten von Nanopartikeln, die man zugeben kann, ob die effektiv sein können bei diesem osteoporoseähnliches Prozess, das im Weltraum passiert, wo die Astronauten sehr viel Knochenmasse abbauen. Es gab eins mit Immunzellen. Das ist eigentlich auch ganz interessant. Man weiß, und es gibt auch verschiedene Untersuchungen darüber, wie sich das Immunsystem und die Immunzellen ganz anders benehmen in der Schwerelosigkeit. Meistens werden sie eigentlich nicht so effektiv sein wie auf dem Boden. Da gab es auch ein Experiment. Es gab ein paar Experimente mit Pflanzen oder mit kleinen Tieren, zum Beispiel kleine Würmer. Die sind eigentlich so klein, die kann man gar nicht sehen. Das war auch interessant. Es war ein japanischer Experiment bei Genetics, wie sich die Anpassungsmechanismen an die Schwerelosigkeit, ob und wie sie sich auf die nächsten Generationen übertragen. Zwar jetzt nicht als eine wirkliche Genenänderung, als eine genetische Änderung, sondern diese ganze Änderungen, die nennt man Epigenetik. Die werden zwar übertragen von Generation zu Generation, aber das sind jetzt nicht wirklich eine Änderung in ADN. Fand ich auch irgendwie spannend.
Die medizinischen, biologischen Experimente sind natürlich ganz praktisch gesehen die einem am nächsten sind. Man muss sich selber die ganze Zeit verkabeln, man atmet da rein, man ist irgendwie mit Sensoren ausgestattet etc. Kann ich mir vorstellen, dass man sich damit auch intensiver beschäftigt, weil da geht es einem ja so richtig um einen selbst.
Ja, weil man auch vor dem Flug dann mehrere Sitzungen gemacht hat. Das heißt, man kennt sie auch sehr viel. Weil die Wissenschaftler, die brauchen immer einen Vergleich. Die müssen zunächst mal die Messungen machen vor dem Flug und dann mehrmals im Flug, um dieses ganze Anpassungsverfahren anzugucken. Also sie wollen jetzt nicht nur wissen am Ende, was sich geändert hat, sondern wie schnell sich das geändert hat. Das ist ein ganzer Verlauf über die sechs Monate. Deswegen machen wir die auch mehrmals. Und dann nach dem Flug machen wir sie noch mal. Weil sie wollen ja auch sehen, wie alles ob und wie alles wieder auf die Normalität zurückkommt.
Das heißt, man ist auch nach dem Flug sozusagen auch noch voll dabei. Neben den ganzen medizinischen, biologischen Sachen gab es aber ja auch noch so ein paar andere, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das jetzt unter Experimente zusammenfassen kann, wahrscheinlich eher sonstige Maßnahmen. Also es wurden zum Beispiel so Cube-Sats gestartet von der Raumstation. Das ist glaube ich auch nicht das erste Mal passiert. Das ist da schon relativ normal. Das heißt, mit diesen Frachtcontainern, also der Dragon-Kapsel oder dem ATV, ATV 5 kam, glaube ich, in der Mission dazu, also das letzte ATV. Das hatten wir ja auch schon mal besprochen, wie toll das funktioniert. Das heißt, da kommen dann so kleine Satelliten mit in der Fracht und die wirft man ins All? Oder wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Das ist eigentlich ganz schön. Es gibt einen Airlock im japanischen Labor, das eigentlich zu klein für Menschen wäre, aber man kann eben so kleinere Sachen dann praktisch rausbewegen in den Weltraum. Das heißt, die werden aufgebaut auf einem Tisch, sagen wir mal, den man rausschieben kann oder reinschieben kann in den Modul. Dann werden diese Sachen, in dem Fall die CubeSats, aufgebaut mit einem Deployer, also mit einem System, den man wirklich rausschießen kann. Das ist normalerweise ein relativ einfaches System, so mit einer Federung. Die werden dann drauf montiert von den Astronauten. Dann kann man diesen Tisch wieder reinschieben in diesen Airlock. Man macht die Tür zu auf unserer Seite, dann Vakuum in diesem kleinen Airlock, das schaut aus wie ein Zylinder, und dann wird die Tür aufgemacht auf der Außenseite. Dieser Tisch kann dann rausgeschoben werden. Direkt da in der Nähe, das japanische Labor, hat auch so einen kleinen robotischen Arm. Da kann man diesen Deployer fangen, mit diesem Cube-Satz. Dann wird er in die richtige Richtung ausgerichtet, und dann wird dieser Deployer aktiviert. Wie gesagt, normalerweise mit einem einfachen Fehlersystem werden sie rausgedruckt und kommen damit auf ihre Erdumlaufbahn. Die Richtung ist auch wirklich so kalkuliert, dass wir sie jetzt nicht mehr treffen.
Also wohin schießt man sie jetzt? Mehr nach innen, mehr nach außen?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau.
Die dürfen ja nicht auf demselben Orbit wie die ISS unterwegs sein.
Deswegen habe ich sie erwähnt. Da muss sie wirklich in die richtige Richtung kommen, dass sie jetzt, wie gesagt, mit uns, dass wir sie nicht mehr treffen. Wir mögen sie ganz gern, aber wir wollen sie nicht mehr sehen.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen normal. Also es werden von der ISS regelmäßig solche Cube-Sats gestartet oder ist das jetzt nur so ein einmaliges Experiment gewesen?
Nein, einmalig auf keinen Fall. Das ist da mehrmals vorgekommen. Man muss es sich aber nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt jeden Tag passiert. Vielleicht in unserer Mission haben wir viermal irgendwas so in eine Umlaufbahn geschossen. Auch nicht immer Cube-Sats. Manchmal war es auch was anderes.
Dann gab es ja noch ein paar ganz spezielle Dinge. Ich glaube, das erste Mal auch auf dieser Mission gab es einen 3D-Drucker an Bord. Das heißt, man wollte selbstverständlich mal ausprobieren, ob das überhaupt geht. Hat wohl auch ganz offensichtlich ganz gut funktioniert. War das jetzt nur so eine reine Forschung? Wie verhält sich das da? Oder ist das sozusagen auch wirklich die Idee, mit so einem 3D-Drucker an Bord Dinge herzustellen, die man brauchen, die man dann vielleicht nicht hochschicken muss?
Der Drucker da an Bord war natürlich mehr für Forschung. Man wollte eben gucken, ob und wie das klappt. Aber das Ziel ist natürlich schon, dass man diese Technologie, die auf dem Boden inzwischen sehr etabliert, das ist so ein Beispiel von einem Spin-In. Man redet normalerweise von Spin-Offs, also irgendwas wird für eine Meltdown entwickelt, und dann kann man das eigentlich auf der Erde auch nützlich finden. In dem Fall ist es eigentlich eher anders. 3D-Drucken ist inzwischen eine sehr etablierte Technologie auf der Erde, und man möchte die entwickeln für den Weltraum. Da ist natürlich die Schwerelosigkeit der Hauptfaktor, wo man sich legitim die Frage stellen muss, wird das genauso gut klappen, wird das anders klappen, was muss man da ändern, vielleicht an der Maschine, damit das auch klappt und so. Das war jetzt mit einem Polymer, also mit Plastik, inzwischen möchte man auch untersuchen, wie es mit Metall gehen kann. Ein anderer Hot-Topic ist natürlich auch Recycling. Also es wäre natürlich gut, ein Material und ein Verfahren zu haben, wo man sagen kann, ich kann etwas drucken, aber wenn ich das nicht mehr brauche, dann kann ich das Material wieder gewinnen und dann irgendwann wieder verwenden, um etwas ganz anderes zu drucken. Das wäre natürlich ideal.
Aber es ist eher noch so eine theoretische Idee, wie man das jetzt wirklich auf der Raumstation verwenden könnte oder gibt es da so ganz naheliegende Dinge, wo man sich eigentlich wünscht, dass das morgen schon so weit wäre, dass man alles in alles umwandeln kann?
Ja, wenn ich mir mehr denke, zum Beispiel Werkzeuge. Also wir haben im Moment auf der Raumstation ganz, ganz viele Werkzeuge. Meistens nicht nur einmal, sondern zweimal, weil wenn einer verloren wird, dann ist es trotzdem gebraucht. Das nimmt natürlich Platz weg. Also auf der Raumstation ist kein Problem, die Raumstation ist riesig. Aber wenn man sich vorstellt, für die Zukunft so ein Syslunar Habitat oder so, das wird jetzt nicht so groß sein wie der Raumstation. Und wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel jetzt nicht alle Werkzeuge unbedingt mitnehmen muss, sondern jetzt vielleicht so ein Hauptset, das immer wieder gebraucht wird, ja, aber irgendwas, das nur für den Fall gebraucht wird, dass ein spezielles Ding dann kaputt geht, dann könnte man sich vorstellen, bringe ich nicht mit, sondern wenn das wirklich mal gebraucht wird, kann ich das drucken. Und wie gesagt, idealerweise, wenn das nicht mehr gebraucht wird, kann ich das Material wieder gewinnen und am nächsten Tag vielleicht ein anderes Werkzeug drucken.
Ja, oder sozusagen auch ein Werkzeug bauen, was für bei einem Notfall, wo irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist, was man so nicht vorgesehen hat. Da man sich überlegt, na ja, jetzt können wir ja das hier mal bauen, weil mit diesem Haken kriege ich das dann sozusagen da irgendwie wieder dran. Ja, klingt eigentlich ganz, ganz spannend. Es kommt sowieso langsam alles, was so die Science-Fiction... Das ist ein bisschen auch mein Thema heute. Alles, was die Science-Fiction vorher gesagt hat, das manifestiert sich langsam in der ISS. Und ich habe auch das Gefühl, diese Mission hat da eine ganze Menge dazu beigetragen. Wir haben ja vorhin schon von T gesprochen. Im Anhalter durch die Galaxis gibt es ja auch diese tolle Nutri-Matic-Maschine, in der man nur lang genug irgendwas erzählen muss. Und dann stellt sich das entsprechende Menü einem auch her. Man muss bloß unter Umständen sehr lange drüber nachdenken, was ja gefährlich sein kann. Du hast jetzt eine Kaffeemaschine bekommen. Große Ehre. Es gibt eine Kaffeemaschine, wie hieß die? Espresso, ja? Es war eine Espresso-Maschine natürlich. Was ist daran so schwierig? Warum gibt es das jetzt erst?
Ja, weil eine Espresso-Maschine, da muss man natürlich mit Fluiden, also mit Wasser hauptsächlich arbeiten, die unter sehr hohem Druck steht und auch sehr heiß ist. Das sind alles Sachen, die an sich ein bisschen gefährlich sind. Das heißt, man kann nicht einfach die kleine Maschine von der Küche mitnehmen, sondern man muss sich praktisch dreifach absichern. Das ist die normalerweise Sicherheitsrequirements von der Raumstation. Das heißt, das ist eine ziemlich große Maschine, weil da gibt es mehrere Ventile, die das eben absichern. Das wird keine Fluide unter hohem Druck und mit hohen Temperaturen in die Kabine geschossen. Der Kaffee fließt einfach nicht nach unten, wie auf der Erde. Man muss das ein bisschen umdenken, also mit Pouches, damit das alles schön unten ist.
Also wie das sonstige Wasser und Essen auch sonst kommt, in diesen kleinen Plastiktüten steckt man das da so rein und er saugt sich quasi das Wasser aus dem einen und drückt dann den Kaffee in den anderen. Aber gab es noch eine passende Tasse dafür?
Ja, das war ganz lustig. Gleichzeitig kamen diese Zero-G-Cups. Das war eine Idee, die vor einigen Jahren der Don Pettit hatte. Das ist ein Astronaut aus der Wissenschaft, der sehr kreativ ist. Und er hat sich gedacht... Ich glaube, man denkt immer vielleicht, dass Tassen ein Problem sind, weil die Flüssigkeiten einfach rausfließen würden. Was auf Dauer auch der Fall wäre. Aber wenn ich vorsichtig ein bisschen Wasser in eine Tasse reintu, das bleibt schon da drin. Also langsam würde es sich bewegen. Aber man muss sich jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass das gleich außer Kontrolle gerät. Außer man fängt an, die Tasse irgendwie herum zu bewegen oder so. Das Problem ist halt, ich kann nicht daraus trinken. Wenn ich es einfach so trinke wie auf der Erde, da kommt nichts raus. Dem Wasser ist es egal. Aber er hatte sich irgendwie gedacht, wenn man eine Tasse macht, auf einer Seite gibt es einen bestimmten Winkel, einen ziemlich engen Winkel, den er rausgerechnet hat, dann wegen kapillaren Anziehungskraft, dann fließt eigentlich dieses Fluid auf. Und dann kann man eigentlich aus der Tasse trinken. Und das war der Witz dabei. Und dann habe ich natürlich das versucht, also mit dem Espresso, da fand ich es, ich fand es ganz schön, dass wir unsere Espresso-Zeit hatten und eigentlich aus der Tasse trinken konnten. Und dann, wie gesagt, erst kam der Kaffee aus der Maschine in diese Tasche, so wie vorgesehen. Und dann haben wir das praktisch reingespritzt in die Tasse. Und dann konnten wir mit der Tasse. Ja, gar nicht schlecht.
Also sonst gibt es keinen Kaffee oder gibt es schon auch Kaffee?
Auch Instant-Kaffee. Das sind ja einfach diese Tüten, wo es Puder drin gibt und dann gibt man Wasser dazu, warmes Wasser und dann ist es auch schlecht.
Aber jetzt halt richtiger Espresso, wie sich das für so ein Frühstück gehört. Tolle Sache. Warum hat man das gemacht?
Ja, teilweise wollte diese Gruppe, die das gemacht hat, das einfach mal als Technologiedemonstration machen, dass man jetzt mit diesen Fluiden unter hohem Druck und unter hoher Temperatur weiß, wie man damit umgehen kann.
Bevor wir noch auf die schönen Dinge zu sprechen kommen, da gab es ja noch so einige, wollte ich nochmal so auf die etwas dramatischeren Phasen kommen. Man bereitet sich ja so für einiges vor, aber was dann letzten Endes passiert, weiß man ja nicht. Es gab einmal den Fall, dass man, glaube ich, sogar einem Festkörper ausweichen musste. Da wurde dann die Raumstation angehoben oder hat so eine Ausweichprozedur gemacht. Das ist aber was ganz Normales eigentlich. Das findet öfter statt.
Ja, das findet relativ oft statt und ist eigentlich untraumatisch an Bord. Also wenn das jetzt zum Beispiel über die Nacht passieren würde, dann würden sie uns gar nicht wecken. Also die würden uns am nächsten Vormittag sagen...
Übrigens, ihr seid da gerade etwas ausgewichen.
Genau.
Aber im Januar gab es eine richtige Evakuierung, weil da war dann so ein bisschen Panik, weil bestimmte Sensoren was genau gemeldet haben.
Also wir haben so einen Emergency-Alarm bekommen. Also das ist das, was man ungern hört. Vor allem in den, ja weil Feueralarm hatten wir eigentlich relativ oft an Bord, die waren meistens Fehlmeldungen. Aber dann plötzlich an diesem Tag haben wir dieses Ammoniak-Alarm gesehen. Das ist natürlich sehr giftig. Wir haben Ammoniak in den Kühlleitungen außerhalb der Raumstation, auf dem amerikanischen Teil der Raumstation, nicht auf dem russischen. Die sind eigentlich unter höherem Druck, als die Kühlleitungen innerhalb der Raumstation, wo Wasser fließt. Bei den Wärmetauschern, wenn da ein Leck entstehen sollte, würde natürlich Ammoniak reinfließen, weil der Druck höher ist. Dementsprechend bereitet man sich für diesen Fall vor. Man muss einfach ganz schnell die Sauerstoffmaske anziehen und so schnell wie möglich gucken, dass alle im russischen Segment sind. Die Schleuse wird dann dazu gemacht, dass kein Austausch von Luft mehr stattfindet zwischen den zwei Teilen. Dann wird dann gemessen im russischen Segment, ob da doch irgendwie Ammoniak in der Luft ist oder nicht. Wir haben das dann alles gemacht. Im russischen Segment war auf jeden Fall alles in Ordnung. Dann konnten wir die Masken dann runternehmen und ganz normal atmen und uns mit dem Boden unterhalten. Keiner von uns hatte Symptome. Keiner von uns hat was gerochen. Wir hatten schon den Verdacht, das wären ein Falsalat, eine Fehlermeldung. Aber wussten wir natürlich so richtig, nicht so richtig. Dann haben die Spezialisten, die nicht wussten, das an den ganzen Tagen dann untersucht. Ich glaube, das war gegen neun Uhr vormittags, als das passiert ist. Man möchte natürlich sicherer sein und wirklich verstehen, es war ein bisschen komisch, weil das in ein paar Sachen gleichzeitig passiert. Irgendwie ein Computer hat einen Fehler gehabt und ein Sensor gleichzeitig. Verschiedene Signale, wo die Spezialisten auch praktisch den ganzen Tag gebraucht haben, um das Ganze zu rekonstruieren, dass es auch Sinn hat und die auch mehr oder weniger sicher sein konnten. Das war wirklich nur ein Falsalarm. Dann konnten wir dann vorsichtig zurückkommen. Das war ganz lustig. Man kommt zurück und das war alles ganz leise, weil die ganzen Ventilatoren und Pumpen dann angehalten wurden, um diesen Luftaustausch anzuhalten. Das ist das Erste, was das Computer auch automatisch macht bei so einem Alarm. Es wird alles ausgeschaltet, es wird alles ganz leise und die Luft hat komisch gerochen, als ob man jetzt in einen Keller gehen würde, wo es irgendwie feucht ist und kein Luftaustausch stattgefunden hat den ganzen Tag.
Weil die Luft sozusagen dann von der eigenen Atmung die ganze Zeit angefeuchtet wird, aber diese Feuchte wird nicht mehr aus der Luft herausgenommen?
Gut geatmet hatte da keiner mehr, weil, wie gesagt, wir waren ja evakuiert im russischen Segment, aber ja, irgendwie, es hat sich so, ja, es hat ein bisschen so gerochen als ein Kellerluft oder so. Nicht in dem Teil von der Raumstation, also nicht im amerikanischen Teil. Da war kein lebender Mensch mehr den ganzen Tag.
Aber als wir dann zurückkamen, das heißt, am Ende wusste man aber auch, was es war, also was jetzt der eigentliche Grund war für diesen Fehlarlauben?
Ja, wie gesagt, es war eine Kombination von Events, die irgendwie gleichzeitig stattgefunden haben. Und ja, im Nachhinein kann man das nachvollziehen und erklären, aber klar, in dem Moment war es jetzt nicht so einfach, alle Teile von diesem Puzzle zusammenzutun. Ich meine, die Raumstation ist auch ein ziemlich kompliziertes System, eine komplizierte Maschine.
Auch eine ziemliche Herausforderung sind ja diese EVAs, die Ausflüge nach draußen. Du hast keinen gemacht, aber dein Kollege, ich glaube der Terry Wirz war das, als er da war, der war draußen unter anderem, also auch die anderen beiden. Da gab es doch was, da ist doch wieder dieses Problem aufgetaucht mit dem Wasser im Helm.
Ja, wobei es jetzt nicht so dramatisch war, wie jetzt bei Luca, bei Armitane, vor drei Jahren oder so.
Genau, bei dem war es ja schon richtig viel Wasser im Helm, will man ja nur überhaupt nicht hören. Man wundert sich natürlich so ein bisschen, warum das dann gleich nochmal passiert ist, obwohl man diesen Fehler schon mal hatte.
Ja, ein bisschen Wasser im Helm, beim Wiederbedrucken vom Airlock, wo es eigentlich bei Terry dann passiert ist, ist eigentlich ein relativ bekanntes Problem. Es ist eigentlich nicht so gefährlich, weil erstens ist man auch wieder da, schon im Airlock. Und es wird, wie gesagt, man ist dabei, wieder Luft einzulassen, das heißt, innerhalb von ein paar Minuten ist auch die Schleuse wieder offen und man kann dann Hilfe haben, aus dem Helm abnehmen und so weiter. Deswegen sind wir alle sehr sensibel. Und heutzutage, erst nach dem, was jetzt bei Luca passiert war, wenn jemand sagt, ich habe Wasser im Helm, dann sind wir natürlich alle sehr sensibel. Und wir gucken. Ich habe auch gleich versucht, weil ich meine, ich habe das auch gesehen und ich habe auch versucht, allen klarzumachen. Das ist jetzt nicht dramatisch, das ist nicht lebensgefährlich, weil ich wusste, die Leute auf dem Boden, die machen sich jetzt immer sehr viel Sorge, wenn sie hören, Wasser im Helm. Aber ich habe das gesehen, das war jetzt nicht viel. Und ich bin schon davon ausgegangen, dass jetzt keiner stirbt. Und ja, dementsprechend.
Was ja auch noch so ein Teil der Arbeit ist, neben diesen ganzen regelmäßigen Tätigkeiten, ist so ein bisschen auch der Kontakt mit der Öffentlichkeit. Du bist ja auch schon eine ganze Weile lang am Twitteren und sicherlich auch noch auf anderen Kanälen unterwegs. Der eine oder andere Berührung gab es ja dann auch in besonderen Momenten. Also Leonard Nimoy ist gestorben. Schöne Gelegenheit, mal den Vulkan Salute ins Foto zu bringen. Da hast du dann auch gleich die nächste Science-Fiction-Rolle nochmal ausgefüllt, so ein bisschen wie Catherine Janeway mit dem schönen entsprechenden Trekkie-Shirt. Als bekennender Trekkie dürfte das ein besonderer Moment gewesen sein. Aber wie ist denn das Verhältnis zu der Öffentlichkeit? Also denkt man darüber nach, dass man da jetzt sozusagen über der Erde ist und so eine große Teilnahme, also spürt man überhaupt eine Teilnahme der Leute auf der Erde? Wie ist da dieser Austausch?
Ja, ich meine, man spürt es auf jeden Fall, wobei wahrscheinlich nicht ganz. Also man ist schon ein bisschen in einer Bubble da oben. Also man kriegt nicht alles mit. Gut, es gibt Astronauten, die möchten das alles mitkriegen und man kann das dann absprechen mit den Teams auf dem Boden und man kann sagen, alles, was irgendwie über meine Mission geschrieben wird, das möchte ich sehen, schickt mir das, Videos, Fernsehberichte oder so. Das wollte ich eigentlich auch keinen Fall. Deswegen habe ich auch nicht so wahnsinnig viel mitbekommen. Also jetzt gerade in Italien, ich bin ja Italienerin und es ist immer ein bisschen so, bei uns ist Astronauten, da ist natürlich jeder der Held oder die Heldin im eigenen Land, wobei wir natürlich europäische Astronauten sind. Und ich war schon überrascht, als ich zurückkam, was für eine Präsenz die Mission dann gehabt hatte im Fernsehen und in den Berichterstattungen und so weiter und so fort. So viel hatte ich jetzt nicht mitbekommen oder erwartet. Aber jetzt gerade was Social Media angeht, da kann man schon gucken. Ich meine, dass es gut ankommt oder schlecht ankommt, meistens eigentlich gut, und dass die Leute sich begeistern.
Habt ihr denn eine richtige Internetverbindung da oben?
Wir haben eine Internetverbindung, die ist auch sehr, sehr langsam und umständlich. Nee, nee, also viel, viel schlimmer. Es ist manchmal wirklich wie diese Dialog Modems von den 90er oder so. Also teilweise wirklich sehr umständlich.
Aber ihr könnt ja selber direkt los twittern, oder geht das alles nochmal durch irgendeinen Proxy?
Also man kann direkt los twittern. Man loggt sich eigentlich remotely ein auf eine Maschine auf der Erde. Und diese Maschine ist dann auf dem Internet. Also keine eigentliche ISS-Maschine ist auf dem Internet. Das wäre natürlich unsicher, aber das wäre keine gute Idee. Es gibt ganz separat Computer, die wirklich nur dazu da sind, dass wir uns einloggen können auf eine Image in Houston und dann auf das Internet kommen. Aber wie gesagt, das ist schon umständlich. Also es ist nicht so, dass ich jetzt irgendwie Lust gehabt hätte, da rum zu googeln, was jetzt über meine Mission gesagt wird.
Das wäre zu umständlich gewesen.
Dann nahm die ganze Mission am Ende nochmal eine interessante Wendung, weil es ja diesen Fehlstart einer Progress-Kapsel gab in Baikonur, die dazu führte, dass die Mission verlängert wurde. Auf einmal, ich weiß nicht wie viel, wurde dann noch hinten dran gehängt.
Ein Monat ungefähr.
Ein Monat. Das heißt, bis letzten Endes nochmal einen ganzen Monat länger auf der ISS geblieben, als ursprünglich geplant. Damit waren es gut 200 Tage, kann man sagen. Also es fehlt, glaube ich, so ein halber Tag. Und jetzt bist du ganz nebenbei auch noch Rekordhalterin für Frauen im Weltall geworden. Das ist sicherlich etwas, was keine besondere Bedeutung hat. Trotz alledem ist das natürlich eine lange Zeit, die man jetzt da oben gewesen ist. Jetzt ging es wieder zurück in die Kapsel. Was denkt man, was denkt man in dem Moment, wenn das dann alles vorbei ist?
Ja, ist eigentlich ganz komisch. Das erste Mal, als wir eigentlich hätten zurückkommen müssen, ich glaube, ich war mental gar nicht vorbereitet. Es hätte sich für mich sehr abrupt gefühlt. Man ist so busy, man hat ja so viel zu tun. Man arbeitet ein bisschen auch die ganze Zeit. Es ist eine richtige Auszeit, um sich mental vorzubereiten. Okay, da geht etwas zu Ende, es geht wieder zurück auf die Erde. Hatte ich jetzt nicht unbedingt gehabt. Und dann kam noch dazu, dass eben ein paar Wochen vor der geplanten Rückkehr diese Sache mit der Progress passierte. Dann haben wir lange Zeit eigentlich nicht gewusst, ob wir wirklich länger bleiben oder nicht. Das wurde eigentlich der Last Minute entschieden. Aber dann war es mental noch schwieriger, weil eigentlich habe ich gehofft, dass wir bleiben. Trotzdem musste man sich vorbereitet auf die Rückkehr. Wenn sie mir dann doch gesagt hätten, jetzt gehst du wieder nach Hause, dann wäre es sehr abrupt für mich gewesen. Und der extra Monat hat mir eigentlich sehr geholfen. Ich habe das ein bisschen verarbeiten können. Zu dem zweiten Versuch war ich mental mehr vorbereitet. Ich glaube, ich hätte das ein bisschen abschließen können, so mental für mich. Und es war dann okay, zurückzukommen.
Trotzdem ein kleines Geschenk sozusagen zum Schluss noch.
Genau, so habe ich es empfunden.
Wenn man jetzt zurückkehrt, man geht dann wieder in die selbe Kapsel, mit der man gekommen ist, ist es dieselbe?
Ja, auf jeden Fall dieselbe.
Da ist ja immer noch eine zweite, manchmal auch noch angedockt, oder?
Ja, das ist für die andere drei.
Die Rettungskapsel sozusagen?
Nein, das ist die Kapsel von den anderen drei. Man ist ja sechs Leute auf der Raumstation.
Die müssen auch zurück, aber man fliegt sozusagen mit der wieder zurück, mit der man auch gekommen ist. Was passiert dann? Man wird abgekoppelt?
Genau, man wird abgekoppelt. Die Triebwerke werden ganz kurz angeschaltet. Man gewinnt ein bisschen Abstand von der Raumstation. Man geht um die Erde, glaube ich, einmal. Das ist so eine Art Pufferzeit, die eingeplant ist, für den Fall, dass etwas schief gelaufen ist und man hat länger gebraucht. Der erste große Milestone ist natürlich, dass der große Triebwerk angeschaltet werden muss, um die Soyuz ein kleines bisschen abzubremsen. Das ist wirklich nicht viel. Der läuft für ungefähr vier Minuten, ein bisschen mehr als vier Minuten. Man wird ein kleines bisschen abgebremst, aber das reicht, dass man jetzt nach einer halben Umdrehung um die Erde, die Umlaufbahn wird ein bisschen tiefer und man stößt zusammen mit den höheren Schichten von der Atmosphäre und man wird dann von der Atmosphäre, man fängt an, gebremst zu werden. Zunächst mal ein kleines bisschen und dann, je tiefer man kommt, desto dichter wird die Atmosphäre und dann wird man mehr und mehr gebremst. Und dementsprechend wird es auch in der Kapsel teilweise ein bisschen unangenehm, weil, wie ich vorhin gesagt hatte, ich meine nach 200 Tagen Schwerelosigkeit ist einfach ganz normales Gewicht unangenehm und dann wird es natürlich auch viel höher. Man kommt eigentlich zweimal über vier Gs bei einem ganz normalen Wiedereintritt wie unserem. Man fühlt sich wirklich so gedruckt in den Sitz und deutlich unangenehmer als jetzt beim Start. Das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen länger.
Ist das laut?
Ja, es wird teilweise laut. Man muss ein bisschen zurückgehen. Nicht die ganze Soyuz kommt zurück, sondern nachdem der Triebwerk abgearbeitet hat und wir abgebremst wurden. Das nächste ist eigentlich, dass die Soyuz in drei Teile geteilt werden muss, weil nur der mittlere Teil, das sogenannte Wiedereintrittsmodul, das Scentmodul, das ist das einzige, das den Wiedereintritt auch überleben wird. Deshalb hat er so ein Hitzeschild. Und die zwei Teile auf den Seiten, das Teil mit dem Triebwerk, also das Servicemodul, und dieser Hunde-Orbital-Modul, wo zum Beispiel die Toilette drin ist, die werden dann abgekoppelt, wirklich mit so kleinen Explosionen. Man fühlt wirklich diese kleine Explosionen, die stattfinden. Und dann gehen sie weg, und sie brennen dann die Atmosphäre auf. Und dann, wie gesagt, mit dem Wiedereintrittsmodul kommen sie zur Erde zurück. Ganz am Ende, wo die Schichten wirklich dicht sind und es wirklich sehr, sehr warm wird, dann ist es wirklich wie ein Feuerball. Also überall drumrum ist Plasma. Man fehlt ja auf die Kommunikation, weil durch das Plasma kommen die Radiowellen nicht mehr. Und wenn man rausguckt, dann sieht man wirklich Feuer. Feuer, das vorbeigeht. Das ist eigentlich ganz lustig. Und dann der nächste sehr dynamische Moment ist, wo der Parachute, also der Fallschirm, dann aufgeht. Das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich gewaltiger Stoß da. Und dann für 20 Sekunden oder so, dann ist man wirklich rumgeschaukelt, weil die Kapsel muss natürlich langsam zur Ruhe kommen. Und dann ist es ungefähr 10 Minuten oder so relativ ruhig. Ich meine, man kommt ja langsam runter unter diesem Fallschirm. Es war bei uns eigentlich superschön. Es war da in Kasachstan, die ganze Rettungs-Subschrauber und Flugzeuge, die haben uns sehr schnell gefunden, Kontakt aufgenommen, die fangen an mit dir zu reden. Ich meine, die sagen, ja wir sehen euch, schaut alles gut aus. Die sagen dir, wie hoch du bist. Und am Ende machen sie so eine Art Countdown. Also die sagen, ja 500 Meter, 400 Meter, 300 Meter auf die Landung vorbereiten und dann BUMM, dann ist man da. Dann ist man auf einmal da.
Und superschwer.
Und echt superschwer, also man fühlt sich wirklich, also unglaublich schwer, alles fühlt sich schwer, einfach so eine Hand hochzuheben, etwas ganz Leichtes zu tragen, wie ein Papierbecher, das man in der Hand hält. Man hat den Eindruck, da ist etwas ganz Schweres, das auf die Hand druckt, obwohl es eigentlich nur ein Papierbecher ist. Da muss das Gehirn sich wirklich auf das Gefühl vom Gewicht und vom Druck auf den Körper wieder dran gewöhnen. Und das dauert schon, ja, 24 Stunden oder so, einfach mental, um sich dran wieder zu gewöhnen.
Also gar nicht nur, weil der Körper sich jetzt so detrainiert hätte, sondern einfach weil der Kopf davon ausgeht, nichts hat mehr Gewicht.
Ja, es ist wirklich eine Perzeption vom Gewicht. Die ist völlig anders. Ich meine, es hat jetzt nichts mit Kraft zu tun. Ich meine, wir trainieren eigentlich im Weltall. Wir waren eigentlich in guter Form. Es ist nicht, dass ich jetzt wahnsinnig viel Muskelkraft verloren hätte. Zumindest nicht auf den Hauptmuskeln, also auf den kleinen posturalen Muskeln. Klar, die kann man schlecht trainieren, aber auf den großen Körpermuskeln, die man sowieso trainiert, mit Squats und Bicep Curls und so weiter. Ich hatte jetzt nicht unbedingt viel Kraft verloren.
Ja, du hast ja auch jeden Tag zwei Stunden trainiert da oben.
Genau, aber es ist wirklich nur mental. Ich meine, das Gehirn erwartet das alles nicht mehr. Das fühlt sich alles komisch an.
Das Gehirn möchte auch schon wieder zurück. War doch so schön. Kann man sich jetzt so Filme wie Gravity oder so als Astronaut überhaupt noch anschauen?
Ich hatte mir damals angeguckt, als es rauskam. Ich fand es ganz lustig. Ich habe mich totgelacht im Kino.
Ja, Samantha. Die Zeit ist natürlich immer sehr beschränkt bei Astronauten, ich weiß. Ich habe mich trotzdem sehr gefreut, dass wir jetzt hier noch mal zusammenkommen können. Ich wünsche auf jeden Fall alles Gute für eine weitere kommende Mission.
Danke schön.
Irgendwann wird es vielleicht noch mal eine geben. Das neue ERC-Team ist ja nicht nur angetreten, um jetzt einmal kurz irgendwo zu sein.
Ja, danke dir und alle im Osseren Hören.